how to select the right business partner
so I got a great question for my youtube
viewers love you guys guru kalyan who
wrote in the say hey Evan how's it going
to watch help your videos your advice is
great i'm a fourteen-year-old hoo splash
would become an entrepreneur I let them
know more about selecting the right
business partners as I'm a friend who's
talented in the way that I want but I
feel confused whether the trust him and
I feel he may betray me or be more clear
not be the right person to work with
problem is I'm not sure that I would
find someone else who will share the
same thoughts as mine so this is a great
question and one that a lot of
entrepreneurs go through right you're
trying to build this thing up you
realize you can't do this all yourself
and and you want help you want something
to help you build this thing and when
you're on the same page with somebody
when there's somebody who has
complimentary skills as you it's really
wonderful you know you know you're not
in this all alone you have somebody who
who's feeling the same pressures and
pains as you and kind of understands
would be going through so it's great i
love that part of a partnership the
thing about partnerships is people rush
into it too soon a lot like marriages
right foot this is like a marriage
having a business partner is like having
a wife or a husband you're going to
probably send more time with your
business partner than you will with your
wife or husband as sad as that may sound
so you guys better get a lot you know
you better be on the same page you
better want the same thing and you
better date before you get married just
like you would with a husband or wife
right don't just rush into it it's so
easy at the start you know I have this
great idea yeah I agree to this is great
and then you launch into it and then you
realize all these things about each
other that that aren't going to work
right and anybody can be friendly and
happy when things are going well but
what about during the crappy times you
know when you're not making money when
you're not hitting the marks you thought
you were going to hit and you're
struggling are you still going to get
along there and so you need to do two
things one you need to test somebody out
okay if you're starting a business with
somebody there are there
to be there has to be things that you
work on in a small scale first so the
people who I've worked with in the past
even people who I just do joint ventures
with you know revenue shares with not
not big you know here here's a piece of
my company that big picture I'll always
start on the smaller thing first just to
see if you can work together so start
something smaller work on some projects
together see if you can handle working
with them or not see if you're on the
same page you'll figure out pretty
quickly it was working out or not the
other thing is you have to trust your
gut one of my favorite thoughts on this
comes from Robert De Niro in the movie
Ronan where he was saying whenever there
is doubt there is no doubt meaning that
if you are questioning yourself then you
know what to do it's not the right
decision so you're worried about this
person you know being you know not a
good person to work with you might stab
you in the back but behind your back
whatever then you know you already know
that's the answer you cannot work with
this person it's not a good decision and
you don't want to let the fear because
it's the fear right you're like well
what if I don't find anybody else this
is the only person who I've ever found
you can't let that fear force you into
the wrong decision right let's same
thing as we mentioned getting married
you know you're with this you're a 14
year old i mean you mean you're not
thinking marriage yet i hope i don't
know ah but if your guy right you're
with some girl and you know she's not
right for you but does well I've never
been with anybody else and I don't know
if I'll ever find anybody else you don't
want to let that fear of not finding the
right person force you into making a
lifelong terrible decision right that
other person is there there are people
who want to help you who believe in the
same thing to see you whose personality
matches yours whose value matches yours
will be a much better fit to work with
and that's what you need to go fine and
the way to do it and start hanging
around those circles so say you need I
don't know what your roles are seeing in
a programmer you need somebody to
program your ideas you should be hanging
around
programmers go to events where there are
programmers go to meet ups go to
conferences hang out in online forums
where there are programmers talking
about things you want somebody here's
your ideal fit okay you want somebody
who has the same values as you who
treats people the same way as you who
sees the world in the same way as you do
who loves what you stand for whatever
business you're trying to create they
have the same vision they have that same
passion so those things match up and
then they have complementary skill sets
so they're the programmer while you're
the CEO or whatever your role is right
so you need to get those people who have
the same vision same values want to do
this thing but also have the
complementary skill sets to support you
and until you find that person don't let
other people take a piece of your pie
those are watching I'd love to know how
you found your business partners success
stories failure stories let me know in
the comments below share your story to
help inspire other entrepreneurs are
going through the same thing if you guys
like this video thumbs up below look at
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon